okay well Sunday it's Mother's Day yeah
so happy Mother's Day time others
there's out there I'm just a cat mom
yeah
so what's on the list we got anything to
talk about
um I kind of wanted to talk about oh one
thing that we've been talking about this
morning one person who they made a
recommendation in the YouTube comments
yeah and we think it's a fantastic idea
so much so that we might actually do it
yes right we might make a cookbook yeah
yeah we can I can do that I think that's
a great idea we'll take pictures and put
one together I'll put some stuff in
there some recipes yeah interesting
recipes it'll be there 13 o'clock
cookbook well give it will give it to
patrons and then just sell it to other
people
yeah we can have like a little cocktail
section you you like a spam spam section
although I protocol it spam cuz you
probably get sued I probably got spiced
ham section you could put serious
recipes in there too but it's funny you
know yeah it's gonna be a mixture
everything I think that's what I think
it would be super fun yeah I mean I had
um in case I don't I don't know if I
probably mentioned it before but um I
designed the this satanic spell book the
black vegan black metal chef his
cookbook it is for sale on Amazon I
designed that yeah
dad sold a lot of copies yeah and now
through us but through him he yeah he
printed them all up yeah yeah but that
was like actually super fun to do and
like it's like because I get to because
I got to make it look like all deaf do
we have one of those around here I do
it's like it's right up there yeah grab
that thing hold on this thing's great
it's full-color yeah we'll make it like
this hardcover showing the inside of
that thing I think is beautiful yeah I
think I've done this before
yeah Brian took Brian took all the
photographs yeah so he just gave me all
the photographs than the [ __ ] yeah we
did she did the layout and did all did
everything but yeah we can we'll do
something like that
yeah I was thinking of doing something
like that yeah probably wouldn't be that
big though
I like how like ya know I'm not gonna do
it like I think it's funny too the way
he always has he
have like funny names for all the
recipes like invoking the Majestics run
of scampi and instead of saying
ingredients he says spell reagents yeah
and you know so he has and the cool
thing too is he has like a little QR
code like on every menu and if you scan
it with your phone it goes right to a
YouTube video that shows him making it
and he took like a photo of every step
of the these are all vegan recipes
obviously but uh he's got photos of
every step of it pretty much yeah okay
so uh and it's funny like he wrote like
all these little like sidebars and [ __ ]
like that so that's kind of like what we
were thinking well we hadn't really
thought about doing a cookbook before
but then when somebody said it in the
YouTube comments they're like man like
we could do the photography and stuff I
can do that yeah Venna Nate's the stuff
the plate presentations and take
pictures of it I don't think with the
kind of stuff that I make you probably
wouldn't need pictures through the whole
thing probably add pictures of the
finished product I mean Vince I'm
probably the recipe is yeah you might
need pictures of like a couple of the
steps that they were implicated or
anything I have my pizza section to show
you guys how to make pizza dough yeah
and then how to make the sauce and
everything because some people in shift
it [ __ ] that we eat around here and
stuff that we eat on the show yeah
drinks yeah we should all the drinks and
then like yeah pizza you make like a lot
of Indian and Thai food Thai food
Chinese food that yes so did some white
trash food let's do some white trash
food yes other stuff you can do your
paprikash recipe yeah do that some of
the Brazilian stuff that you make it
yeah yeah corn bread special corn bread
Mexican Mexican corn bread that's
another one he used what else did they
used to make like these that make
everything he does yeah making making
ravioli never made those in a while
yeah you have a pasta maker do we have
all the Chinese food yeah yeah yeah we
make a lot of Indian food and Thai food
yeah Chinese food I feel like yeah and
pita yeah but yeah so I don't know I
just I thought that'd be fun and it's
like you know I have a lot of other
projects too but we can do it just like
a little bit at a time
yeah over the next couple months want
some of those sandwiches on that bread
yeah yeah kind of bread is that I forget
what it's Co what like pita bread no
square wants Shibata ciabatta yeah yeah
make sure bothers yeah you may come up
with some good recipes yeah you got all
kind of like fun [ __ ] cuz we make good
stuff all the time
probably how to keep it most of it just
like simple food
yeah that you know what I mean just
regular people can cook at home yeah
nothing that you have to be super bright
super skilled at skill that it's really
like you know and and you're really good
to it just like looking in the pantry or
the fridge and like coming up with stuff
coming up with something you know I mean
it's like hey we could do this and that
like something I wouldn't have thought
of because usually I'll just dump stuff
out of a can honestly cuz I'm lazy but
um oh another thing I wanted to talk
about to okay so this is how we spent
our Saturday night you guys because we
recorded the next episode of the show on
Friday night so Saturday night we were
like oh let me watch a movie or
something like that and then we saw on
Netflix that they had added the fifth
season of hoarders oh yeah man that [ __ ]
so guess what we ended up was watch
three hours of it that's like three
hours I have like a [ __ ] Bloody Mary
and I'm just like sitting there watching
it know just like getting I had to take
a shower after once more and more
horrified well I know it's just the good
thing about watching that is that it
just like makes me want to clean like
afterward it's just it's it's really
frustrating to me because I mean my
grandfather was a hoarder not to quite
the extent as some of the people on his
show but it was still on the show but it
was still pretty bad and he did it to
two houses like he had one house and not
kind of filled up and then they tore
that one down and then he moved to
another one and he filled that what
happened to and then when he died like
my mom and all the rest of her siblings
had to go in there and clean everything
out it was just like dumpsters and
dumpsters and dumpsters with the stuff
but I mean some of the people in here
this is like some next-level yeah I mean
that's just nothing he just put boxes
and [ __ ] he just had boxes and [ __ ] dude
they have [ __ ] old ladies in here
that are [ __ ] and pissing on the
floor and living in it and then Sheen
and their dogs up to [ __ ] and piss on
the floor live in that and it's just
like they come in there and they try to
reason with this woman and this is some
kind of modern thinking I know they're
trying to put on a show but that shit's
not supposed to happen you can't reason
with a person like that as soon as a
person's [ __ ] on the floor and
[ __ ] in cups and leaving it around
over you're just supposed to be locking
them up you can't reason with a person
like that they've lost all [ __ ] reason
because yeah it's sad because there's
some people on there that I actually
because like the second um the second
episode we watched which is like a guy I
think it was that big was in Fairbanks
Alaska and he at least I mean it was a
mess and like he was kind of more like
my grandfather cuz he just like kept
buying cars and boats and he had like a
huge oh like a beautiful like five acre
lot and he had like a hundred cars like
just turned into a junkyard and you know
what I mean and at least he didn't have
like a [ __ ] ton of neighbors and stuff
like that that were suffering but he at
least knew that he had a problem I mean
he had a hard time like getting rid of
stuff and like he didn't want to sell
the cars and things like that but he
knew that it wasn't right and he knew
that it yeah I have a feeling that
people knew that he had that weakness
and instead of [ __ ] taking [ __ ] to
the junkyard just go to him you just go
hey I know you like old stay hey look at
this car what this car I imagine you're
like he probably was like if he gave me
200 hours she could have this car it's a
totally [ __ ] worthless old [ __ ]
like 82 oh yeah because they're like hey
take it back I need to get rid of you
know the Manion he'd buy it so I think
other [ __ ] too but that was just kinda
he kind of kept out had a weakness for
[ __ ] taking jars at cars on forklifts
yeah junk shake yeah I paid $1,000 for
it he's probably lying but he probably
didn't pay anything for that [ __ ] I
think a lot of them like get into like
and like I said he I kind of felt sorry
for him because he had had like a lot of
like his wife died and then like his
daughter died I believe of a drug
overdose and so he had had like a lot of
problems and like you know he so he
lived alone like out in the middle of
nowhere and he didn't really have like a
lot of people to like look out for him
and [ __ ] which is kind of the same thing
that happened my grandfather because he
wasn't a hoarder until after my
grandmother divorced him and cuz she
used to lived in the house that was and
it was gorgeous and she kept it clean
and everything but the second she left
it's like he just started filling it up
with stuff and so I kind of felt bad
for him because it he at least knew that
he had a problem and seemed to one he
wasn't like actively hostile or anything
like that the other two that we watched
like the first couple these [ __ ]
people oh my god they were just like
this horrifying they were a hoarding
couple yeah they thought that the
government had been taken over by Nazi
communists
yeah come wait wait and caught him
another old communism Nazism ship Nazism
ships now and now he is some ship yeah
they thought Trump he thought Trump was
gonna save him that but you but you look
at the dude you know he thought the
government was coming after him you know
the Trump you gonna see one of those
like but the [ __ ] delusional
you know I mean they were both
delusional there was a couple the entire
[ __ ] house then the front and the
back yard they were showing a drone
footage the difference between his house
and everybody else's house and it's just
like a middle class lower middle class
kind of area his [ __ ] property is
packed it's like a dump it looked
exactly like don't look at me like a
[ __ ] dump just rotten trash every
rats rats it's a menace to society it is
see you know I mean that you could smell
that [ __ ] house you know [ __ ] they
said you can smell that house from a
distance yeah and all the neighbors came
to help him to pick all the [ __ ] up to
get it all out they were sick of it
I don't blame if you live next to it and
the people living next to that houses
we're fighting off the rats yeah neat
things Trump's gonna save him
it's a trump megger save you bro you're
[ __ ] making rats they he basically
every time like somebody came and I
should say that the liberal comedy
become a Nazi Nazism ship people that he
kept blaming but you know bitching about
like you know the code enforcement
people they gave him every opportunity
they they started giving him citations
in 2012 and then they didn't do anything
it's like you know what I mean they kept
saying hey you know you want city people
like it you want them to come out and
help you clean it up for free and this
guy still was like oh help me help me
I'm so oppressed and I just couldn't
like oh oh and they stole my dogs I'm
like you were keeping the dogs in Elkin
in a cat carrier yeah in a tiny little
hall with
crap everywhere and they were pissing
and [ __ ] where they were and you
weren't letting them outside to run
around or anything like that yeah I just
thought it was funny that so yeah they
took your [ __ ] dogs away and it
wasn't it wasn't the Liberals doing this
[ __ ] to him nobody was doing his mind
his we just thought it was like he was
just like a dick
he was a [ __ ] both of them it was a
couple they were [ __ ] they were
lunatics
the cops jackbooted thugs they had a big
cardboard sign it's like she took a
picture and put it in her [ __ ]
Twitter and all yeah [ __ ] is the matter
with you people
yeah because you know the cops and the
people that were dealing with it were
nice to him and I was saying way nicer
to them than really they probably
deserve and I have to say well I just
thought it was bizarre that he was
calling them Nazi liberals commie Nazi
Liberals when I'm looking to do now I'm
going now that did pry food for Trump
well it's like it's he just say if you
didn't if you weren't going his way he
thought you were completely delusional
he was like sitting the wall I goddamn
it this is America and I have a right to
like live in the middle of a [ __ ]
garbage dump where it's like you know
what I mean
it's like honestly if I didn't live next
door to you I probably would have got
there to set your [ __ ] house on fire
while you were in there who was that
dude the city something-or-other he was
like that was code enforcement or more
unfortunate I think he's like yeah
you're free but you're now free too damn
contaminated the whole entire [ __ ]
neighborhood no goddamnit
rats and roaches they're all just like
my rights I have the right to do this
and that I'm like oh and so nobody else
have rights just you is that how that
goes he had the right to [ __ ]
contaminate the [ __ ] everybody else's
[ __ ] and force them to live in his smell
yeah and it was like the wife too they
were they were both terrible terrible
people
and it was one of the worst things that
I've ever seen yeah and then like the
last one that we watched I mean that
woman was clearly clearly very very
mentally yeah she was [ __ ] in a cup in
front of her [ __ ] grandchildren yeah
cuz her grandchildren had to stay there
for a while because their mom got put in
jail like this you're gonna cop some
pudding in there and then just [ __ ]
throw on the cup in the middle of the
[ __ ] she would she would pee in a cup
and hand it to her grand daughter and
put it out Oh
dump that out by the bush and then the
the bathroom worked
yeah bathroom worked and then and and
then she was she she got taken out of
her house and was moved into her
daughter's house which is a clean place
and she kept doing that in their place
she would like this on the bathroom
floor yeah and then and and poop on [ __ ]
on the floor she'd piss in the cups and
[ __ ] put put the glass up there
[ __ ] in the UH on the [ __ ] table
and that was like a drinking glass like
who does that the thing that's the thing
I would ever Santos seen some of this
some of these mental health people and
everything I don't [ __ ] get it well
there are some people that I think are
just probably too far gone and she was
much older I mean she will probably have
to be institutionalized because I'm
saying that from the beginning and
they're still trying to reason with her
yeah but like I said they do have to
make a show out of it they are trying to
give everybody on there like as much
opportunity because some people actually
do like the people on there like are
really really frustrating but sometimes
like they'll have a breakthrough and
they'll be like oh and they'll figure it
out but there have been some people not
many there's like a handful that this
woman like last night there was one a
couple seasons ago that I'm thinking of
they're like a really old woman where
you just can't seem to get through to
them because they just don't understand
it's like home it's like in that movie
Bronson when he goes to the asain asylum
and that dude just shifts on the floor
and then just picks the [ __ ] up and [ __ ]
starts [ __ ] rubbing it on his face or
whatever and play with it and that's
like an old trope that you go to these
damn insane asylums and people [ __ ]
[ __ ] on things it's a trope for a
reason because there's yeah there's some
people regress their brains get so
[ __ ] fraud that they regress into uh
it's not even primitive behavior because
animals don't do that it's just [ __ ]
yeah that's like an animals not do that
there's a barrier they try to stay away
from it it's like a containment yeah
they know better it's just so I can they
start glitching out and doing weird [ __ ]
like that and that and when a person
does that that's just a sign that
they're [ __ ] gone yeah I mean the
thing about it is that that this is
actually not the only floor [ __ ] that
has been on this on hoarders I think a
couple seasons ago there was that one
and she was at least [ __ ] in plastic
bags but she was keeping the plastic
bags whatever reason um and it was like
and it ended up collapsing the floor in
her bathroom now her plumbing did not
work and she could not afford to fix it
but shall we ever go it out but yeah
that was another thing why didn't you
throw it out with the greatest put it
out in a garbage but you see she has
some kind of [ __ ] weird
she couldn't throw anything away nothing
even I don't [ __ ] well so this woman
that we watched last night was like that
too because her whole pretty much her
whole entire house was just covered with
human feces just it was just garbage the
whole floor was just garbage and a
neighbor said that [ __ ] trash never
got put it she never she never put the
trash out like as many years as she like
that just means that the garbage stayed
in the [ __ ] dog [ __ ] all over
everything mice and rats [ __ ] all
everything they went in the house and
like all over the walls it was like fly
[ __ ]
yeah um like a dump and it was like the
dump and a [ __ ] cess pit all you know
the main [ __ ] in that house I mean
and I had to go into that I don't know
how like the people on the show [ __ ]
do it because I mean yeah I know they
have like masks and hazmat suits on and
stuff but it's like even the thought of
it like I'm sitting there just watching
it on TV I can't even smell it or
anything just the thought of it just
makes me gag forever I don't understand
how like people can go and I can't
imagine I mean like I said after after
my grandfather died I went into his
house while my pinball my you know my
aunts and uncles and my mom were
cleaning it out and they had already
cleared some of it out and he wasn't
like you know it was mostly just stuff
it wasn't really garbage or anything
it's like there was some kind of [ __ ]
like that in there where he didn't throw
like an old can away that he beans out
of or something like that but it was
mostly just stuff that he collected like
he liked guns and cameras and jewelry
and that yeah so he just had like boxes
of that kind of crap or books but um you
know it was dirty but and the floor had
clawed the stairs had collapsed and some
like parts of the upper floors had
collapsed also but it wasn't like you
know it wasn't like filthy in the dishes
just like [ __ ] smeared on stuff because
that like I said that's some of the
hoarding on there is bad but that is a
whole other level
because she didn't really seem to see
any problem with it like she wasn't at
least the woman that was [ __ ] in the
bags like before at least she was like
embarrassed about it so she had enough
wherewithal enough self-awareness to
know that that's gross you know not not
enough to actually throw the bags away
but this woman that we saw last night
that was just like pooping on the floor
like wherever she sat apparently um she
didn't really seem to know why it was a
big deal there's something to be said
about you know with what they used to do
in earlier ages you know I mean they
have her and they wouldn't enforce
health codes you know if there was a
complaint did going looking to go this
person is filthy and they'd lock them up
they're gone they they're incapable of
taking care of themselves they do now
they are but they give you a lot more
you leave me much leeway you know yours
they're supposed to go in there and go
this is a violation of about the help
bunch of health codes this person is
[ __ ] insane they can't take care of
themselves they got to be an assist
assisted living and that's the [ __ ]
funny farm and they put him in there
they need to bring all that kind of [ __ ]
back now that one dude was saying he
thought the Democrats were doing it he's
nobody's [ __ ] talking about because
that that wasn't something new they used
to enforce that a lot more strictly back
in eighteen hundreds even early 1900s if
you lived in your own [ __ ] you were
considered to be [ __ ] crazy yeah
which I think you're [ __ ] crazy and
well to protect you and other people you
got to go yeah you got to go like I said
I think the thing that happens too is
that it happens a lot with like these
older people and these older people are
kind of like socially isolated maybe
they live alone maybe their family has
moved away so I think it goes on for
such a long time because no one really
knows what's going on in there and it's
like sometimes when you know if they
have neighbors that have never been in
the house they're just like oh it smells
bad or we saw some rats or something
like that that's a sign though then yeah
but I'm just saying that they probably
that probably city code enforcement they
get like a lot of reports like that and
it takes a long time to get around to
like check in a mountain [ __ ] especially
if it doesn't sound like it's anything
that big a deal so I can see how it
happens there's gotta be
now it's
gotta depend on States counties alright
let people forget that counties have
different [ __ ] rules - if there's
reports or any evidence that they're
sucking bad [ __ ] going on in a house
they got to have what's called like a
Health and Welfare inspection yeah you
sent somebody in there to make sure that
there's [ __ ] power and that there's
water and the trash is being taken out
and you and if this person can't manage
themselves you got to be
institutionalized yeah because it's a
[ __ ] threat yeah yeah it's like other
people live threat of civil as a person
exactly because there there's creating
disease and vectors for disease and
they're putting themselves at risk it's
just a sign that they can't live on
their own yeah and I mean all of these
people it's like you know with their
houses or fire hazards if their house
caught on fire if something happened to
them like firefighters medics and stuff
like that wouldn't be able to get in
there because there's just [ __ ] every if
a house was on fire
firemen would go in there and save that
person and try to [ __ ] save that
house you don't mean yeah there's no
difference between a house on fire and
somebody who's living in their own [ __ ]
or their Oldfield yeah because it's the
same [ __ ] thing they could see Fred
said neighbor's house red just like fire
okay right and and that's a sign that
there's something wrong with that person
that they need help you know I mean it's
not a violation of their freedom that's
what I mean it's like this those two I
mean they seem to like they were just
trying to rationalize what it was they
were doing
yeah and trying to vilify people and
keep him away that's that's what it was
yeah they were just like really really
this horrible crotchety and like old
people and they're just like sitting
their whole entire house I don't think
you could you couldn't see the floor
they were just like sitting there was no
place for him to sleep they were just
like they were just like leaned up
against like the piles of crap he cooked
in the bathroom yeah and you should have
seen that to it he would like sit on the
toilet yeah he had like a hot plate I
guess or something like that oh they're
cooking like eggs
damn [ __ ] mold [ __ ] going on the
outside of it and everything
they were [ __ ] nasty man it was holy
crap it's like I don't mind a little bit
of clutter but [ __ ] sake man their
families and their descendants were
letting them get away with it
he had that beta ass son who wouldn't
[ __ ] tell him yeah well he they got a
bunch of kids but I think the other ones
didn't live around there yeah they left
yeah
but they knew that it was going on they
were they just I think they were just
knew that there was that it wasn't worth
it they were like a [ __ ] well the
thing about it was the son had fought
with the dad like millions of times and
then finally he was just like and I'd
probably do the same it's like if you
just got into the same argument with
like with your boy over again with them
over and over I'd just be like well [ __ ]
it you know what if you just want to
like live and have it avalanche on you
and get buried like Collier brothers
then that's on you me and Jenny was
[ __ ] saying man what if we lived in
one of those houses next door and I was
I was going Jane that I'd is that
[ __ ] all right down yeah I wait -
those [ __ ] are asleep [ __ ]
take a damn [ __ ] road flare throw
that [ __ ] in that backyard
yeah I mean it's been going on for 20
years I knew that there was no like
innocent animals in there and also if I
knew that it wasn't gonna spread to
anyone else's property because that
would suck if that happened but it would
have because it had that wooden fence
that went around it but it looked like
you should have seen it it looked like a
[ __ ] dump man I mean you're like
literally a dump it was like six feet
thick of trash yeah inside and all over
the whole backyard and most of the front
yard
and we've it's one of the worst ones
that I've seen yet I mean we've watched
like pretty much every season of that
because it's like I don't really I don't
like a lot of reality shows but that one
it's just like yes and it pretty
separate and it was literally rotten
trash yeah she opened a had a they had a
van it looked pretty new opened it up
and it was nothing but just those little
tiny shards of paper that little mice
make yeah almost all the way up to the
[ __ ] ceiling the whole [ __ ] van I
don't know if the car ran out there it
was just like in the driveway and then
she kept like yelling and fighting
people to keep the [ __ ] paper in
there yeah she's like oh no no
everything's contaminated yeah
stand that it's like rodents have peed
and pooped all over every single thing
in this [ __ ] car you're gonna have to
like you know they're gonna have to
pretty much just set it on fire I just
feel like a lot of the times I watch
this show it's like I could never be
like an OCD and hoarding therapist like
some of these people can do because I
would have just like zero patience yeah
I just feel well yeah I'm just like look
I'm you're going to the funny farm and
we're gonna bulldoze this [ __ ] and we're
gonna [ __ ] down yeah and we're gonna let
somebody that appreciates it have it
because they try to reason with him and
I just get so [ __ ] frustrated the one
guy that the one old guy the one old guy
that thought everyone was commie Nazis
yeah um liberal liberal yes yes he
wanted to keep a four year old bottle of
Mountain Dew yeah you had to feed it to
animals and he was gonna give it to
animals because they're like look these
are a found a case they hadn't been
opened I don't think but um he's like
yeah you know these are four years old
you might want to throw these out no no
I I give these to the animals they love
it and they're like you were giving
animals one mountain dew to expired
Mountain Dew I I don't think that's such
a good thing to be doing but it's like
he just would not let that and he's
sitting there with it like in the yard
and he had it done like that's the hill
you want to die on huh four-year-old
bottle of Mountain Dew this is what your
life has come here we plug that oh yeah
honor up on a more positive note I found
a channel on YouTube
this has most at least it has many of
the [ __ ] classic and searches from
the 70s I was watching the one on it on
Amityville Horror I think I watched that
way back when we did the show about them
it was good I think I found it I Leonard
Nimoy trying to talk about that case you
know making it in the head [ __ ] ed on
it ed Warren it Warren doing a whole
[ __ ] spear to pop is all headed yeah
yeah this is good though there's
something about the tone of those old
episodes I love it sir yeah I'd say yeah
I think a lot of it had to do with like
Leonard Nimoy like does everything he
could narrate like whatever it could be
like the biggest [ __ ] and they but
yeah
it's like he made it sound scary and I'm
just like you know I believe it some
kind of gravitas yeah and he also had
like the access it's true they had the
priests that did the blessing of the
house they had him [ __ ] you know him
blacked out just his silhouette and like
I used to do back then yeah I think he's
since come forth had me I you know he's
met a bunch of paranormal movies I can't
get that dude story straight because I
think that he has kind of like gone back
and forth about whether he even went to
the house or not okay
cuz sometimes he's like yeah I went
there and they did good like there was
the whole thing or whatever and they
were supplies but then like later he
said no I never he went to the house I
just talked to him on the phone and then
like no I really did go and then her
voice said the case was based on fact
yeah and the very beginning of they have
to say that they didn't know back on
fact based on the fact that people did
get murdered in the house that's true
yeah but that's probably about all
that's true I'm not a whole show on that
that's one that and that is one of our
more famous ones in it yeah I think
we've got a lot of hits on that show we
didn't everybody knows nobody knows that
case but that case though it's an
interesting case it's a fun case to
listen to and I used to believe it but
over time and when I got more experience
and you know of course after Mammoth
Mountain happen you know Mountain case
that I was involved in that case just
has the fingerprints of so many
different phenomena all piled onto the
same case it can't be everything at once
it's got elements of poltergeist
haunting did but not really demonic
possession I think it's just it's just a
sign that they picked a bunch of
different phenomenon put it into a case
well yeah I'm just trying to make a good
book it's a chimera case is a chimera
they wanted to make something of yes but
when you take each little account or any
little story out of that case some
phenomena that did that they described
it sounds fascinating yeah maybe that
did happen cuz it was kind of like
something happened to me or this one was
kind of like something happens from this
other case but there's all these
different phenomenon in the same
case it's just a sign that it was a
chimera that they were picking things
and putting it - yeah like what sounds
the scare like rub it into a narrative
sure that's what I think happened
working with it ya know that it was an
era it was another era back in those
days if you could come up with a good
story you might be able to get a book
deal and a movie deal and make a lot of
money on it but that only happened you
know maybe a couple times yeah I mean I
feel like the 70 times over kind of like
the big heyday of like paranormal kind
of like based on a true story type of
[ __ ] cuz look I mean you you even had
stuff like like reincarnation like
Audrey Rhodes yeah all that kind of
stuff that was supposedly based on a
real story and all that kind of stuff
that was there was like a big thing for
that in the 70s yeah I think that was
because of the Exorcist yeah it
definitely was yeah The Exorcist
appeared it was a huge hit all of a
sudden every religious [ __ ] everybody
wanted a piece of that so they started
coming whoa what about poltergeist what
about you know reincarnation what about
you know so they're all coming for these
different angles what about the
Antichrist what about Antichrist yeah
yeah was pretend it was good for that
well it was like a one-two punch I think
of robots
Rosmer yeah of this car of Rosemary's
Baby in the Exorcist do you know I mean
coming out like within a couple years of
each other yeah I think it's what did it
and then suddenly everything was like Oh
Satanism you know that was probably on
the back of 2001 because because they
believed that sci-fi was not respectable
and that that couldn't make money and
when 2001 a Space Odyssey came out
people loved it even though I think it
was kinda uh I don't think it did that
well at the box office I don't think so
either it doesn't seem like something no
but it made it respectable I think in
this and I think I think I think the
paranormal movies were kind of done on
the back of that so with Star Wars yeah
well the thing about Rosemary's Baby and
The Exorcist is that it was about like
you know mythological kind of stuff like
Satanism and everything but it treated
it very seriously which was all religion
yeah which was something that
you know was unusual it was yeah well it
was unusual for a horror movie to like
take itself seriously yeah that usually
they were just like fun or gory or like
a wacky like big bug movie or yeah like
that a lot of young people don't
understand that during the time that
that the Exorcist came out and also the
one with the damn Antichrist what was
that one called at the element at the
omen yeah
that religion was very out of style yeah
but it those movies helped kind of bring
it back into style oh yeah big time and
I think that [ __ ] caused the satanic
panic yeah it was definitely a big
factor yeah had those movies not come
out and I'm not like [ __ ] on this
movie they're great movies but I don't
think there would have been a Satan but
there probably wouldn't have been yet
because I think there was like a big
resurgence
fundamentalism I guess yeah religiosity
was coming back you know I mean if maybe
it would have come back anyway uh I
would maybe it was just part of the
whole zeitgeist or whatever but um kind
of generational changes it does it does
seem like that kind of like spurred it
along yeah those movies coming out and
being about exorcism stuff I wonder if
like [ __ ] people like Bob Larson and
stuff like that would have had a career
if the Exorcist said Bob Larson was he's
like oh oh he was the guys would go on
all the shows right yeah the backward
masking and everything yeah yeah I mean
there was more than one but he's
probably like the most famous I'd say he
might still be alive
he's still an exorcist he's got like a
bunch of daughters I think and stuff too
and they I think they also do exorcisms
I have one of his crazy books that he
wrote a like back in the 80s somebody
gave it to me about rock and roll yeah
well it's about like all different types
of rock and roll Dungeons and Dragons
like all you know all us evil people
wearing black and worshipping the devil
one yeah like we do I remember I've
started getting to that Dungeons &
Dragons my grandparents [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
didn't know what they were talking about
that you know because Church people
believe that that came from the devil I
even know that they believe that they're
like no I'm pretty much like no X Games
a bunch of nerds with dice yeah yeah all
that is just using their imagination
yeah Gary Gygax they tell you that
[ __ ] pac-man was satanic I'm sure you
could find at least one person pac-man
is actually that's the devil and it's
eating up little Souls yeah
can't you see those [ __ ] food those
fruit from the garden and the last ones
a bunch of key is the keys to heaven
yeah I can make those [ __ ] narratives
up off the top of my [ __ ] head being
chased by [ __ ] evil spirit Ford for
Oh a marvel ghosts you know that red
ones the devil yeah the pink ones the
spirit of homosexuality gays and the
devil in the maze of life I see exactly
I should have I should have been a
[ __ ] Baptist minister you should have
you gonna get a [ __ ] because you
could come up with that kind of crap all
day long right I'd entertaining [ __ ] put
on a [ __ ] Baptist show women start
singing do you give me a hell yeah
that's just semi heavy metal I have a
striper show up make it money are they
still I think so they still have you
know what's funny though it's like some
people were [ __ ] couldn't stand
striper all right I liked metaled at
that time I was starting to get away
from it as soon as those crazy bands
like that we're [ __ ] showing up like
striper because there was like come on
now
striper got accused of [ __ ] making
money alright that oh well they're just
trying to make money off the back of
religion and now I think they lost money
because of the [ __ ] Christian only if
you listen to their [ __ ] music it was
good enough to make it was good and it
was good enough to make it as a metal
band yeah but the content and it was
just cheesy if you asked me I think it
you know I mean I would buy the standard
even by the standards of the aged man
like had it just been a regular metal
band it would have been it would have
made a lot more money I think yeah I
think so well may they really like to
think that they're murdering themselves
you know no I really could mean oh we
could be making more money if we did all
that devil music but I don't know yeah I
think I think they I think they really
believed what they were saying I think
they did - yeah unlike bands like Slayer
who were just like Satanism for chuckles
yeah they took it seriously
no it was a show yeah that's what I mean
it they were all it was all part of
their life from all the black metal
bands were like that yeah I don't think
any of them well maybe some of them
Norwegian ones that like actually
diamond it may be fun churches and
whatnot but I think most of the ones
over here they were just doing actually
King Diamond said it was a show yeah
he's like I'm not feelin anybody you
know I'm not sacrificing virgins I don't
even think he was big into religion nah
I don't think I think a lot of them are
just kind of like not or just an image
Rieger yeah they were just using that
imagery role-playing and stuff pawn show
much like I said that's why I never is
sold it did and you can make a spooky
music make it as you make it cuz you
know you make a music yes my god yeah
that's a good way of looking at it I
never really saw much difference between
those two things it's all just like a
theatrical but I think's I think striper
was really trying to make a point of no
we are not like that
yeah I really think that they were kind
of serious about that we're not gonna
make money off it because other than
their lame-ass lyrics everything else
was pretty much exactly the thing yeah
it was the quality was okay yeah right
it was okay I mean I didn't notice them
being I mean the music being noticeably
lamer than anything no it was about the
same yeah but the topic the image is
just the idea of it yeah not I mean I
thought was lame well it just sucks all
the fun is yeah yeah and only [ __ ]
religious dudes were into it well yeah
so that narrowed the [ __ ] market down
yeah yeah no oh
say I remember saying thinking that they
were like weren't as good as white snake
or anything you know that's damning with
fear I go on my own going down and road
never know well you're good but you're
not you're good but you know why yeah I
got the white snake
[Laughter]
he's talking about man the [ __ ] white
snake yeah got a peek hood like a
[ __ ] cool yeah just [ __ ] spit in
the noxious poison but I would say that
you know striper might have been like on
a par with like Queens Reich not Queens
right that's better Queens right with a
lot better it's maybe kinda like kind of
like Dokken yeah kind of like Doc you
know what's funny everything like Dokken
you know it's funny because like every
time I wasn't super in a heavy metal
like I heard some of it but never really
my thing
every time I hear the name doc in I hear
but I don't remember who did this it was
like some comedian like back in the 80s
and he's like Dokken you suckin so every
time I hear that [ __ ] hate might think
of that a merit Americans just didn't
really didn't really know how to do
metal until like the advent of [ __ ]
Metallica
yeah it was an LA inspired scene of kind
of semi transvestites well it was glam
rock but it was I don't even think you
guys dressed up and their girlfriends
clothes the girls doing their makeup it
was glamour it was more like the New
York Dolls yeah actual like heavy Mia it
wasn't quite cool I didn't think the
British knew how to do it in the Germans
yeah like I'd [ __ ] love to sit except
they were good although there wasn't a
lot of bands like that and from Germany
a lot of that [ __ ] from Germany was like
the scorpions
yeah which speaking of the scorpions
you know I am you said you were gonna
tell that story about the scorpions yeah
we're running low
I feel like a hurricane you want to tell
her okay
[Laughter]
this has become Tabac
okay this takes us back to the time how
long ago was that about six six seven
years ago maybe yeah man maybe more like
eight or nine eight nine years we had
some we had a some friends of ours that
were a couple and they had a they were
they threw these damn golf nights yeah
every Friday where aisle right and he
was a DJ and his wife Tina was the girl
[ __ ] did the door and everything and
and [ __ ] what does David get [ __ ] Oh
Paul yeah so Paul Paul calls me on a
phone or something I don't remember how
this [ __ ] happened I don't know how [ __ ]
trying to remember how a story well I
think what and initially ended up
happening was that we were nothing and
he played [ __ ] writers like a rock
you like a hurricane like a side I got
no it wasn't a joke dieren a [ __ ]
asset in a goth club yeah
and I heard that [ __ ] and I went like
what the [ __ ] and I looked right at it I
spin it and he's looking at me like uh
yeah well so I said what the [ __ ] you
praying [ __ ] them laugh and drunk it
up put them is it Paul what the [ __ ]
you plant well you know my good friend
requested it now I was just like man you
tell it since this is a [ __ ] goth
night man don't [ __ ] play that [ __ ]
on me and it was later on the night they
were [ __ ] drunk they were out there
dancing to it anyway yeah they're like
whatever we don't care we're dancing I
was mortified he was yeah so must have
been about two weeks later
yeah they throw another event and me and
Jenny were worth driving there and who
was with us it was Kaylee Kaylee yeah
and maybe one other person maybe was
Lisa can't remember yeah
and Lacey Kayleigh was this little cute
little [ __ ] lesbian girl with [ __ ]
kitty ears and a [ __ ] ninja mask and
she dressed up like a goddamn ninja she
probably four foot ten yes yes all right
Kayleigh was with us and Lacey was with
inkless I think you're right Lacey is
this like an skinny guy girl there's big
old [ __ ] ratted out here okay and she
was funny anyway they weren't a couple
they were just friends yeah they were
Swedish friends yeah so we're going
there and I get a text on my phone and
his [ __ ] PO and he's asked me if I'm
coming and I was already kind of three
sheets to the wind if I remember because
didnot wasn't it wasn't that pre-gaming
a little bit yeah because I was driving
pretty sure I just text back Here I am
and he starts coming back and he's asked
me another question you
it doesn't really a kid this is not a
story that I could tell she had to be
there and he's like no I need to ask you
something are you guys come to this and
that and he asked me another question
and I just suck and respondent did that
one rock you like her he's like [ __ ] you
and this and that new stop I know you're
really nice giving these big long
[ __ ] spiels over the text and I just
get in that right out Dan at dad-dad
rock-like and I'm standing that [ __ ]
that's the text and it drove him [ __ ]
crazy
he just kept I kept doing it over
[ __ ] 20 minutes easily he's giving
sending me these long dissertations
about why he played scorpions and I
should [ __ ] pick on him for his set
and [ __ ] yeah and I'm just saying the
lyrics to rock you like a hurricane I
show up to the club me and Jenn show up
to the club we are entourage and and as
I come in [ __ ] his wife's [ __ ]
taking money at the door and her eyes
are all red one's a little bit bigger
than the other which lets me know that
he's been talking to her
wait that time I need to talk to you
I'll be in in a sec she walked by her
and [ __ ] went and looked and I see I
see him Paul behind up and they're doing
his set [ __ ] behind in the DJ booth
he's looking at me and he's having a
nervous [ __ ] breath have a nervous
[ __ ] break
he's just [ __ ] boiling okay
he's big ol dude - you know so I just
[ __ ] show up
I got the girls with me and I start
singing to him rock you like a hurricane
and he's trying to reason with me
okay that's harm I just want to tell you
something right now not yet not noon
you're just having fun I just need to
read it you can't reason with me and
once I get on a roll I'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
reasonable so I just cheap [ __ ] rock
you left and I'm [ __ ] we're here I am
and I got the girls and [ __ ] I'm
reenacted a whole [ __ ] video [ __ ]
boob Ginny's boobs is [ __ ] I'm doing the
whole [ __ ] video former clubs gone
and everything tommye rootin I know
you're just having for me you can't
raise him with me man once I cook him
come at you like that that was the story
and he eventually started laughing yeah
eventually it took a while when he
realized that well I seem to remember
that for many many weeks afterward every
time you came in the club he would say
yeah yeah yeah like got even with me the
second you saw me as soon as you saw me
in the club song a fade out and it go
right dad rock you like a hurricane I'd
have to go out there and [ __ ] perform
it I forgot about that there's all kind
of [ __ ] that's happened I forgot about
yeah yes she reminds me though I yeah
long time ago we had a good time
stories of [ __ ] the ham yeah we have a
lot of stories we'll probably think of
some more like I'll see if I can drive
stories about other people some of them
I can't tell ya I don't really want to
let get too much it yeah
drama another yes we can like talk just
about funny [ __ ] or [ __ ] that we just
big life swaps going on the hotel next
door and all kinds of weird [ __ ] that
was happening that we'd hear about we
weren't there yeah remember that one
yeah they were like - where were you we
thought about do it I can't mess with
the names yeah they were doing it this
is this everybody was watching where
were you yeah we missed it
yeah you should have seen it man what
room was this no right across way when
you go out man you gonna unit fight I
think it's room 23
it's one right there because next to the
club was a hotel yeah and it was like
when those old fashioned hotels and [ __ ]
well they were hopping in over there and
[ __ ] doing all kinds of sexual
perversions and [ __ ] yeah
people we knew and they're like married
yeah a lot of them just funny yeah those
were the days yeah and these are not you
know these are like cute people and you
know just people that you know
multicolored hair and [ __ ]
wow I'm [ __ ] like strippers or ex
strippers or [ __ ] people that work at
Disney and they're taters and funny [ __ ]
like that I mean it is Orlando so yes
Earl and a lot of people are in the
tourism or entertainment yeah
Orlando is kind of light then the way
Hollywood used to be back like in the
50s yeah kinda yeah like you take old
Hollywood and Las Vegas and kind of
combine it kind of like that debauchery
yeah yeah between Orlando and Tampa yeah
Tampa might be worse than Orlando
I think Tampa's worse I waited over
there for a little while but yeah yeah
yes I'm [ __ ] battle on and that's
where I like that were Lando people go
when like it's kind of like it's kind of
like Vegas like what happens in Tampa
stays in Tampa yeah you know yeah they
got a great goth club there called the
castle yeah let me tear up a castle -
been there for a million god she does
all the Flyers for certain DJs at the
castle all the main knights and [ __ ]
and then we've had events and we were
involved in advance down there
it's a big [ __ ] nice Club well they
started doing on Castle Mark Paradise
they started doing last year they
started doing at the absolution festival
which is three days like so the Friday
they started doing
they have like a shop like they have all
the people come and like sell their
wares or whatever yeah we do the shirts
for it yeah and then like the next two
nights Friday night and Saturday night
they have it at two different venues but
like they have like a [ __ ] ton of bands
and they just did the first one last
year and it was like a big success so
hopefully they get to do it again this
me and jenni of course get free run with
place backstage and [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that and hanging out with them yes
because we're staff on those nights yeah
we made all the shirts we had all
started I made all the punches bunch of
new bands I was like really happy to see
like the turnout though yeah like all
the people that came last year it was it
was bigger than half the [ __ ] that would
go down in New York or Boston yeah and
we didn't even go I don't think we went
on the Friday we went on the just we
went on one day like on Saturday we're
gonna say over South song [ __ ] fire
when it comes to club stuff now down
here in Florida Florida's no joke yeah
we've already I mean we've had decent
clubs for like a long time but only
thing is bad about it is that it's hot
yeah so you can't really wear cuz we
have like all these fabulously I mean
you can but you'll [ __ ] burn up
alright so this is probably been our
longest sidetracks yet it's almost an
hour long [ __ ] it's Mother's Day though
yeah it's much special Mother's Day
Mother's Day need to title this [ __ ]
sensationally to get him to watch what
do you want me to copy
[Laughter]
mm well then people are gonna get what
they're gonna click on it there's stuff
on there that's like not on here but
yeah so yeah if I could take some
footage of this [ __ ] that goes on
sometimes you know when we go to these
events and we'll put that on here for
patrons only
yeah yeah you guys are [ __ ] the trip
out yes old farts we get out two legs
it's funny man we're old but it doesn't
really seem like it now nobody notices
now he goes through this we go to this
[ __ ] we're [ __ ] around people in
their 20s and 30s they don't read you
guys are new you guys are 50 yeah well
like I said I was wearing our forties
they didn't know I was talking to
[ __ ] Michael from a starry night one
night at I bar then he said something
about being born in 1990 Yeah right and
I'm like what and I yeah I made a face
like that I was like I graduated high
school
yeah 1890 yeah and he was his point he's
a baby isn't that the same kind of music
as me so it never really I knew he was
younger but it didn't really occur to me
how much younger he was a lot is a lot
of these people like you might see on
Instagram or maybe you're these cam
girls cuz we know some he's big boob cam
girls and [ __ ] when you look at him you
might think that'd be a person in their
20s or 30s no they're in their 50s some
of them are you know Marv they're much
older than you think they are good
people aren't don't age the way that
they used to for some reason a lot of
Goths hold it together yeah I guess
maybe it's cuz we don't go out in the
Sun yeah you know who I'm talking about
yeah [ __ ] those two girls yeah it
looked at they they look on them in a
while but yeah they've been around a lot
but that was they were our age yeah yeah
you'd never know but you wouldn't know
about I mean most of the people that we
hang out with that are our age you
wouldn't I really wouldn't know you
wouldn't know yeah because they don't
look it they don't look at it all I
don't know what it is but yeah so yeah
yeah so she's older than she is Sonya
might be older than me I think she might
be a year by a year or two but no you
would never know about looking at her no
I don't think anyone would ever guess
know that no and her husband is probably
20 years younger than her huh I don't
know about no I don't think he's 20
years younger
she isn't I think he might be somewhat
younger but I don't remember her I think
he's at least 10 years younger
yeah okay I don't like I said I'm not he
might be I'm not I'm not really sure how
old he is though I haven't seen him a
long time either Sonya is this little
skinny chick today we used to hang out
with and she little skinny chick big
boobs big fake-looking
but yeah that kind of like fake
kind of attractive kind of fake funny in
her way
yeah okay I miss her sometimes yeah
we haven't seen her a long time though
she stopped going out like a long time
ago her husband reclaimed her he won't
let her go out with us anymore
too much trouble she could get in
trouble with me sure that's true yeah we
didn't like encourage it we didn't
discourage it either
hey so do you have any ideas about like
what you want title this or no you don't
know you'll come up with something yeah
okay so it's on me I guess on you all
right so hopefully you guys have a
lovely rest of your mother's day and
your Sunday and we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow